[rats squeaking]
Having a swarm of rats crawl up your legs
may seem like your own personal nightmare.
But for Hollywood animal
trainer Mark Harden,
it's just another day of work.
To teach them to climb up his pants
for the 2003 movie "Willard,"
multiple rats had to repeat the task
over and over again at different angles.
Mark Harden: At the beginning,
we certainly want to
make it as easy as possible,
give them as much confidence as possible,
and then we gradually
make it more difficult.
Narrator: But being a rat trainer
isn't just about getting a rat to run
from point A to point B,
although that is a big part of it.
It's also about understanding
the unique personality
of every rat you cast.
Rats are social animals
that can be trained
just like a cat or a dog,
and they have a similar
genetic makeup to humans.
And just like humans, they can have
a variety of behaviors and personalities,
which means rat trainers need to be able
to sort through them
and identify their
strengths and weaknesses.
For each main rat character in a film,
Mark actually needs to find
multiple rat actors to play the part.
In "Willard," Mark used six different rats
to play the main white rat, Socrates,
who was on camera most of the film
doing a variety of specialized tricks.
Mark: This guy's a really good runner.
This guy seems pretty
handleable and stable,
so if the actors have to hold him,
this will be my actor rat.
So you sort of slot them into
the arc of the character.
Narrator: A horde of rats
is called a mischief.
And once Mark has cast the mischief,
the rats need to be sorted
by what they can and will do.
Mark: Henry Ford would be very proud of
how we train rats in the groups.
Narrator: And he has
trained a lot of rats,
even for a single project.
300 for "Bram Stoker's Dracula,"
and 600 for "Willard."
After casting, the first step
is to split them up by gender,
so they don't reproduce while filming.
Then he splits them into smaller groups
and puts them into boxes
based on their assigned task,
which is based on what they're good at,
according to the trainer's observation.
Each box might have a different trainer
or trainers in charge of it.
They might start out
with five rats in a box,
and eventually they
would work their way up
to 20 at a time.
To keep track of who is who,
all rats are tagged on their tail
with a different color marker.
Mark: It was a team effort.
I didn't sit there and have, you know,
600 rats on a leash.
Narrator: One of the types
of rats he wants to identify
early on are the more aggressive rats,
or biters, for safety reasons.
Yes, rats do bite people,
and Mark himself has been bitten.
But in general, they won't go
out of their way to attack someone.
Mark: So, we encourage
biting certain things.
But what you would hand to an actor
would be one that you're
100% sure is not a biter.
Narrator: But let's say
he does want the rat
to bite something on camera.
In this case, a rat that likes to chew
is exactly what he'd want.
The trick is putting food near the object,
then eventually putting
the food inside the object.
A biter rat will chew its
way through to get to it,
just like they do in
this scene from "Willard"
with the newspaper
and this scene with the tires.
Mark creates a special
mixture of nut butter
and food coloring, which
he paints on a prop.
For example, in this scene in "Willard,"
the rats were actually
chewing fake balsa-wood legs
covered in this edible paste.
Mark: If I want him to look
like he's biting a finger,
I'll just put some scent on the finger.
Not enough to make him want to taste it,
but enough to make him interested.
Narrator: If a real bite is
required close up on camera,
usually a prosthetic is used,
with fake blood of course.
No matter what the rat's
personality or specialty is,
they all have one trait in common.
Mark: The problem with
rats is they're very
sound sensitive and smell sensitive,
and they're very tactile.
So when you're training
them, as soon as you move,
it's all different, right?
The first smell that wafts through
that they don't recognize, they shut down.
Narrator: So the more details about a set
he knows in advance, the better,
so he can prepare them for anything.
Let's look at this scene in "True Blood"
that Mark worked on as an example.
A rat needed to run on
dirt through a tunnel
while a camera was pushing towards him.
It then had to crawl through
a grate and run to a mark,
where it would then stand on its hind legs
and transform into a human.
So Mark needed to first
identify a good runner rat
who could deal with these obstacles.
He replicated what it would look like
as much as possible in his training area,
using a simple dog toy on a
paint stick to mimic the camera.
And how did he get the rat
to move in the first place?
No matter the personality, he has to use
several basic behavior-modification tools
to get it to do what he wants on command.
First is positive reinforcement,
in which he rewards the rats with food
after the trick is complete.
Or he might reward them with safety
by giving them what's called a sanctuary.
Mark: We have little plastic shoeboxes
with a little mousehole cut in it.
They're dark, they're black.
They're very attractive to a rat.
Their food's in there.
So we start introducing
them to the concept of food
and sanctuary at the same time.
Narrator: But food alone isn't
going to get a rat to run.
Often, Mark also has to take advantage
of its flight reaction
by making a loud sound.
Mark: A rat is built to deal with stress.
If you don't give them any stress,
they tend to do self-destructive
behaviors anyway.
So, their whole psychology is built from
scurrying from this thing to that thing.
Narrator: For the "True Blood" scene,
Mark made a makeshift rattle with pebbles
to get the rat to run
and rewarded it with
a sanctuary at the end
where it would get food.
Mark: And then we start
increasing the distance,
but we add a buzzer to it.
[buzzer sounding]
So we're calling them
and giving them some
aversion to being here
while we're calling them there.
So by the time you get on set,
you usually, just the buzzer is enough.
But if he goes sideways or something,
you might wanna shake your little stick.
Narrator: To get the rat
to hit its final mark,
he used an almond-oil scent
so it knew where to stop.
He uses this same basic method
when he needs specialized tricks,
like jumping or climbing.
Mark: They behave well on props.
They can walk tightropes and go up ladders
and do things like that.
Narrator: Let's say he wants
a rat to jump in a scene,
a more difficult trick for a rat.
He puts the food behind him on a platform,
so the rat has to use his
shoulder as a bridge to get it.
Then he gradually increases the distance,
so it has to hop over.
Or if he wants it to climb his leg,
as we mentioned earlier,
he puts the food at
waist level off camera,
so it needs to go up his leg to get to it.
And sometimes he needs to adjust the props
to give the rats a boost.
For example, in "Willard,"
they created a set of prop steps
that the rats could easily run down
that were much shorter than the ones
Crispin Glover would use.
Now, working with a
single rat is one thing,
but what happens when he needs
a whole group to do something?
How do their personalities change?
Mark: The groups become individuals.
I mean, if you have a group of 300 rats,
you break it down into manageable pieces,
and those pieces each
become an individual.
Narrator: And each rat
needs to learn the trick.
They won't follow the
herd or follow a leader,
like pigeons or other flock animals.
Mark: As groups, they're all stupid.
One rat will never lead
another group of rats
through something difficult,
but one rat will stop
an entire army of rats.
Narrator: A common scene
with rats in movies
is swarms of them running together
from one point to another.
Let's look at an example of how a group
of some runners were
trained for "Willard."
Mark starts by putting
each box one at a time
on top of a table in the middle of a room.
He opens it and has them run to
a different sanctuary
box at the other end.
He does this on a table,
both to get them out of their comfort zone
and so they're easier to control.
Mark: They naturally want to hug a wall.
So, I'm in the moviemaking business,
so anything they wanna do
naturally we train against,
because chances are that's not
what you want in the movie.
Narrator: He will
gradually lower the table
until the rats learn to run on the floor.
Mark: And then we start introducing them
to multiple surfaces.
They'll run over carpet,
they'll run over wood,
they'll run over tile.
We'll put water, we'll put dirt,
we'll put whatever they need.
Narrator: Lastly, he
preps the groups together
on the actual set.
Usually, two rehearsals is enough.
In groups, rats all need to be weighed
two to three times per day to make sure
they are all eating and healthy.
Faster, smarter rats in the group
will get to the food first more often,
so Mark occasionally needs to identify
and remove them to let the
other rats get the prize.
So a lot of time on set
is spent just making sure
the animals are all safe and healthy.
And just how strong is
their group identity?
Mark: We would prep the blue team,
then we would prep the red team,
and then we'd turn them all loose
and see what they would do.
And we kept track,
and about 85% of the rats
ended up in their own boxes.
Narrator: Many films these days use CGI
to create realistic animals like rats.
But with CGI, you're also
losing the personality
that comes with the real thing.
Mark: It's really less
dynamic and less dramatic.
Narrator: And you just
wouldn't get that same
visceral reaction watching
a bunch of CGI rats
crawl up a human leg as you
would with a real swarm.
Mark: On one time in
the rehearsal, the rat,
one rat got inside my pant leg.
And that just freaked me out,
because you got 100 rats on the outside
and one on the inside.
And it was the freakiest feeling.